All right. Let's go take a look at the big reveal,
for how it actually started.
Up here is our string; we start at characters zero, on line 1, with ' This '.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5--now we're on line 1, character 5, with the ' is '.
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11--we're on line 2, character 11,
and we're starting the Left Angle, then the ' b ',
then the Right Angle, then the ' webpage '.
And to reverse engineer this, you might note--for example--
that you know the Left Angle is 1 character.
If it starts on character 11, and the ' b ' comes right after it on character 12,
there must be no spaces between them.
Similarly, since the ' b ' is 1 character and it starts on character 12,
the RANGLE, there must be no spaces between the ' b ' and the RANGLE.
So the real trick here is figuring out what happens
after the "is" and before the ' b ',
and knowing that you need these 3 extra spaces
ao all the action's happening here.